you don't post much or at all well
things have changed a little since 2016
Megan Fox is now a bit more active on
social media and giving us a rare
glimpse inside Halloween with her three
sizes of six year olds no four year old
Bodhi in two-year-old journey the 32
year old posted some pics from her
outing with the boys Megan given us her
best Hermione Granger from the Harry
Potter while little his son journey was
a unicorn middle son Bodie was a gecko
from Disney's PJ masks and Noah
seemingly channeled his mom has Jennifer
from Jennifer's Body she's actually evil
not high school evil it would be nice to
make some things that they can see yeah
because you know something like
Jennifer's Body I'm not gonna let them
see for a long time so they like Jonah
Hex I'm not gonna see ever no one should
ever see that movie shared a lot in that
2016 interview including why she is so
selective about what she posts kids do
you make that choice to kind of give
your kids that I'm just normal life as
possible my kids in particular I'm
enrolling them in a school where you
know technology is not allowed until
they're much older and then they're
introduced into computers and things
like that because they will need that
eventually it's a function in the real
world but as children they shouldn't be
around it at all in my opinion and so my
kids won't have cell phones or tablets
or or any of that it interferes with the
brain development I'm really big into
this I'm very passionate about it and
I'm just passionate about it in general
because it's such a platform for not
just bullying but for body shaming
for making people feel badly about
themselves and Instagram has turned into
it's really just an art page where
everybody edits their photos it's not
it's a curated version of their reality
I don't even know what is the point
unless you're promoting something or
unless you're selling something I don't
understand why teenagers need to be on
Instagram making their boobs look bigger
what is happening to the world